oh that's not looking good water that
might be waters a little pixelated
you think hey guys what's up welcome
back to potato mode the show where we
take the most beautiful games we know
and turn them into mush
my name is Joey I'm joined by jean-luc
psyche Oh Joey our car it's broken down
it is broken down because we are playing
Final Fantasy 15 mm-hmm this game was
actually recently released on PC a
couple months ago one of the biggest
selling points was that I had really
really great 4k resolution really really
enhanced graphics from like the ps1 Xbox
ps4 Xbox one versions too bad for that
because we're gonna make it look like
crap oh right now we have the game
running at 1080p with everything on the
highest settings we have even the Nvidia
others like the additional and video
things turned on so I think like hair
works is on but also we have the
resolution scaling that maybe I think
it's up to 125 percent so we got a
little bit extra bump even though we're
not running completely at 4k how much
this was in 4k right here okay how about
how about this I'll when I get back to
the other computer I'll record it in 4k
and then have that at full resolution in
the 1080p screen okay so that way you
can have the full resolution Gladio less
[Music]
crap this game opens like this I know
its slowest opening ever but it's pretty
though very pretty
yeah I got really really nice textures
on pretty much everything here the butts
the mountains the clouds let's watch the
clouds but yeah car car looks nice
everything nice and shiny okay so I
think the appropriate thing to do here
is just maybe we can just go on a couple
of quests yeah like early on you know
just kind of see the sights a little bit
and then we'll start doing some terrible
things to the graphics afterwards but I
also want to I also want to go on maybe
a road trip you can take the car
somewhere dude that's like the best part
about this game it's just a bunch of
boys on a camping trip having a good
time I don't care about the main story
of this game at all I just spent my
whole time camping trying out new
wonderful recipes yes so I think we
could we can brand this as how about the
ugliest road trip ever all right I'm in
first things first run out run out just
at the very least look at the land
because I will admit this is pretty
pretty nice-looking yeah I would maybe
consider replaying this on PC nice okay
I think that's enough of that
let's go to the options take a look at
the display here what are you well we
can we can go up to 4k or we can just go
back down 720 which is what exactly what
I'll do all right Oh a bad now as for
the graphics there's a preset so instead
of the highest settings we're gonna go
down the low actually let me make sure
this resolution scaling down 50% because
you can't have 720p mm-hmm goggle lower
than that all right we're good okay Wow
yeah our frame rate actually a frame
rate looks a lot better now but as you
can see there are a lot of things wrong
with this shimmering a lot of the [ __ ]
the shimmering on the grunt on the grass
it looks like the mountains lost quite a
bit of detail there yeah all the
textures just started faded away
let's see let's see how they held they
look not bad what he still looks pretty
good like his hair is weird but honestly
like they you can tell there's some high
quality stuff underneath so let's get
rid of that pretty game alright let's do
that and of course everyone's favorite
friend being video profile inspector
we're gonna get real ugly with this one
yes thanks looking moon oh so we got the
load game right this has all been
redacted
we can't know any of this oh my god
where's his face there's no face on
Noctis at all it's all hair okay full
disclosure I did so I've ran tests on
this like a month or so ago and I
completely forgot about everything that
actually happens when you take away all
the textures for one I kind of like this
new look for about this more hair
somehow it's like they added hair wait
wait we're Cindy oh please talk to Cindy
you know Cindy hey what's up oh okay
which one are we doing here for yeah yes
No what the hell is that my car Joey I
think we are living large here Wow let's
make let's make that bright blue wheels
this one our ice-cold our ice-cold uh I
don't even know what to call this it's
it's supposed to be camo no I mean like
just the no I'm just talking about the
car in general it's like part monster
truck part like rolls-royce ish kinda
yeah I don't know it's like a Hot Wheels
it looks like some kids Hot Wheels were
they they broke off the top half of one
and they stuck it on to like something
that's not hot wheels but like the
knockoff ones and they just you know on
top of the other one
okay I'm just gonna do manual yeah
manual you can tell that was manual just
by the length of the word I think
there's there's some squares in front of
us I feel like I want to do math right
now
all right so we got on our drive but we
could still take a look at those oh I
don't drive to where I think it's some
oh is it not although driving no it's
not now we might have to swap cars to
get it to fly
yeah that's why I figured I'll just I'll
make it to the closest oh that's not
looking good oh there's water that might
be waters a little pixelated
you think I mean pixels indicates like
oh no it's polygons they're mine pixels
are sharp yeah whoa oh nothing good type
of thing to worry about guys whoa what
are all these why I see okay I think
these are part of the game maybe once
you finish it once you beat it unlock
everything but that's not how they're
supposed to look are they
maybe it's like an unlockable color for
them I don't know regardless familiar I
I can't tell if this is intentional or
not guys if you know anything or if you
have any idea what's going on with these
purple dudes the kacct was a Keck door
yeah what like just one why are they
human sighs - why are they purple and
three why are there so many of them all
over the place is they just take over
did was there some secret ending that we
did not see oh this is rough this guy it
looks like he belongs in hitman right
here
I mean square right ya know one of these
guys is definitely agent 47 eating photo
rookie cooking with Oh show me them
photos
No I'm so excited they didn't even know
you took a picture of our cars we can't
forget that okay
oh oh my god what is this photo I don't
see anything oh look at that
what there's some orange people what the
is that another one of the CAC tours or
those who might be those Imperials what
the hell but you just got an axe
oh is this normal no it skillfull Orange
like why are these guys all orange I
have no idea what's going on here
88 miles an hour 88 what are we at right
now all our dowels are broken Oh get off
the ground
[Music]
holy crap look at my car okay now did
you just fly anywhere we want we can fly
anywhere we want turnarounds spots you
know it's funny about the ground the
land here is that you can kind of see
where the artist kind of dug each of the
the crevasses right it's like a ZBrush
model yeah I've added the texture work
you know what it's really quite
beautiful yeah I think one thing that
I'm really starting to like about potato
mode doing this whole show is kind of
seeing what the artists like had
intended like originally mm-hm like I
feel like this show is very much an
exploration of just the game of games
graphics I guess graphics in general and
how they work I don't think we'll ever
get that deep into it but whoo I'm gonna
go down here well these are just true Oh
God how's everyone doing
guys all right something to remember the
experience by oh yeah we're gonna pose
for this right oh who is that whoa who
are you who are you why are you in our
picture I got an achievement for
apparently immortal photobomb that's
really creepy can we destroy this photo
all right guys it's been a pleasure our
final night together before what before
before we all die from that a person in
the photo all right what do we want for
our final meal
oh that sandwich I think we have to have
this sandwich are these toppings I don't
know additional stuff
I love the camera
[Music]
all right everyone out
[Laughter]
so big big thanks to a lot of people for
suggesting found fantasy 15 for us
big thanks actually low spec gamer who
does an incredible YouTube channel on
very similar topics about getting games
to perform at like a reasonable level on
like really really poor performing
computers and he actually suggested I
try this out because it is it is a trip
I'll tell you right now oh my gosh okay
look pretty cool though yeah I actually
kind of dig this I love how they don't
have arms that's like the best thing
Stubbs oh hi oh good we can ride hi
alright so now that we've gone the
benchmark tool done thank you guys so
much for watching this episode of mode
if you have a game that you'd like to
suggest make sure that is a PC game
because I cannot do it on ps4 but if you
have a PC game leave in the comments
below you can send us a tweet and we
will see you next Friday
Oh Oh
she's fine she looks okay his mama keeps
changing so they got these really highly
detailed models and they're like
surrounding this just I know you're ugly
abomination of a person they're trying
to help him okay we're here to fix your
graphics